in this video we're going to start
talking about exceptions to the octet
rule which we've talked about in many
other videos the octet rule is this
notion that atoms tend to react in ways
that they're able to have a full outer
shell they're able to have eight valence
electrons now we've already talked about
some exceptions things like hydrogen its
outer shell is that first shell which
gets full with two electrons so it's
trying to get to that duet rule but as
we'll see there are other exceptions
boron and aluminum for example they can
form stable molecules where the boron or
the aluminum only have six valence
electrons not eight and there are
exceptions in the other direction as you
get to the third period and beyond we'll
actually see atoms that can maintain
more than eight valence electrons and
we're actually going to see an example
of that with a xenon so let's just go
into a few examples given what i've told
you
see if you can come up with the lewis
diagram for aluminum hydride so aluminum
hydride has one aluminum and three
hydrogen see if you can draw the lewis
diagram for that
all right now let's do this together so
the first thing you want to do is
account for all of the valence electrons
aluminum's outer shells the third shells
in the third period here and it has one
two three valence electrons
and then we have three hydrogens and
each hydrogen has one valence electron
and so you add all of this up together
three plus three is equal to six valence
electrons in aluminum hydride
now the next step after that is to try
to draw the structure with some covalent
bonds we don't want to make hydrogen our
central atom that would be very atypical
and so let's put aluminum in the center
and then we're going to have three
hydrogens so one
two
and three and then let's put some
covalent bonds in here
and so let's see how many valence
electrons have we now accounted for this
is two in this covalent bond another two
gets us to four another two gets us to
six so we have just accounted for all
six valence electrons so we have no more
valence electrons to play with let's
think about how the various atoms are
doing so the hydrogens are all meeting
their duet rule these two electrons in
this bond are hanging around hydrogen
and around the aluminum but from
hydrogen's point of view it has a full
duet and that hydrogen as well and that
hydrogen as well but notice the aluminum
over here it has 2 four six electrons
valence electrons around it and so it's
not a full octet but aluminum hydride is
actually something that has been
observed
let's think about another example
let's think about
xenon
pentafluoride
xenon
pentafluoride
cation so positively charged ion here
pause this video and see if you could
draw the lewis diagram for this
all right now let's do this together if
any of this seems unfamiliar
i encourage you to watch the video on
introduction to drawing lewis diagrams
but what we'd want to do here is first
think about our valence electrons
so
xenon right over here it's actually a
noble gas it already has a full octet in
its outer shell so it has eight valence
electrons so xenon has eight valence
electrons and then fluorine we've seen
this multiple times has one two three
four five six seven valence electrons
but there's five of them so five times
seven i'm going to be drawing a lot of
electrons in this so this gives us a
total of eight plus 35 which is 43
valence electrons but we have to be
careful this is a cation it is a
positively charged molecule it has a
positive 1 charge so we have to take one
electron away because of that so let's
take away
one
valence electron to get that cation
and so we are left with 42
42 valence electrons so the next step is
to try to draw its structure with some
basic single covalent bonds and xenon
would be our preferred central atom
because fluorine is more electronegative
it's actually the most electronegative
element so let's put a xenon in the
middle
and then let's put some fluorines around
it five of them to be specific
so one
two
three
four i'm having trouble writing an f
four and then
five fluorines and now let me make five
covalent bonds
one two three four five so just like
that i have accounted for ten valence
electrons because you have two valence
electrons in each of these covalent
bonds two four six eight ten so let me
subtract ten valence electrons
and then we are left with 32 valence
electrons now the next step is to try to
allocate some more of these valence
electrons to the terminal atoms so that
they get to a full octet so let me do
that to the fluorines each of these
fluorines already are participating in a
covalent bond so they already have two
valence electrons hanging out with them
so let's give them each six more so
let's give that fluorine
six
and that fluorine gets six
and
that fluorine gets six valence electrons
and that fluorine gets six valence
electrons and then last but not least
this fluorine gets six valence electrons
so i've just given away
six valence electrons to each of five
fluorine atoms so that is 30 valence
electrons that i have just allocated
and then what does that leave me with
and that leaves me with two valence
electrons that have gone unallocated and
the only place to now put them is on the
xenon and as i said things that are
lower down in that periodic table of
elements especially as we get below the
third period these can defy the octet
rule xenon already has 10 valence
electrons and i'm just i'm about to
allocate it two more to it just like
that so you allocate those two more and
then we have allocated all of our
valence electrons and i want to make
sure i remind myself and everyone that
this is a cation so i have to put that
plus charge just like this but this is
something that has been observed where
you can actually have a central atom
like this that goes beyond an octet
number of valence electrons in this case
it has
2 4 6 8 10 12 valence electrons
now an interesting question is how do
these atoms that are in the third period
or beyond handle more than eight valence
electrons and it is a matter of debate
but some chemists believe that it's
possible because they're able to place
their electrons in their empty valence d
orbitals but once again this is
controversial in the chemistry community